ei pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar que
sejam muito bem vindos já mais um vídeo
e eu tô cansado bakker alho tive agora
fazer exercício físico e vocês sabem os
gostos cansou rápido e agora vamos
brancos na barriga nas costas um bom
tubo eu não era para fazer este vídeo
porque estou cansado mas eu vou fazer um
vídeo para demonstrar o quanto eu vos
amo fosse assim tão grande mas vamos lá
ver quem é que são esses japoneses e um
chinês demonstrou o seu sangue que o
jogo vai marcar a minha mãe que o pai
que ela é minha mãe ela é minha e do meu
pai com uma colher
estamos dentro de uma sala
eu não sei mas este míssil já foi brutal
porque já deu problema é que duas vezes
até e aparentemente estamos numa sala
muito bem equipada com isso faz da
categoria a alguém não pagou a conta tv
que está não funciona neste local lume
sem timbre é um pedófilo que é um serial
killer ou mesmo tempo e o que é que se
passa lá em cima não sair mas nesta casa
tem dois andares esta portable eu não
sei as teclas visto ninguém me ensinou a
jogar um da arquitetura e ao tutorial lo
ou está a brilhar porque isto é um
armário fantasma e teerã giz para nós
não pensamos formas não só não sei ao
certo o que aconteceu mas há barulho na
casa alguém tá aqui dentro estamos na
cozinha e se parece um campo grande 11
lavatório com água super futurista em
janelas com chuva o preço ou não aqui
dentro porque a porta tipo duas vezes
meu também vamos tentar encontrar as
crianças que desapareceram e por que
contornar as voltas de suportar o sangue
em uma banheira assim em casa a greve
tem tudo quadrado aqui caiu não se
esteja a subir escadas
a gente segura é cega muito peru eu aqui
dentro do meu ouvido tudo escuro ainda
pessoal vai mulher pega agora não usava
um boné que vocês vão ver exatamente o
que eu vejo é nada eu não consigo ver
nada funciona culto andar um robô cópias
construir ali não foi escassa não sei se
meu corpo bonito e gostoso lá não
funciona eu não sei o que tenho que
fazer e agora vamos lá ver a parte de
cima pessoal tá tudo escuro não
interessa vamos ser corajoso porque nós
somos os boy ecko época vamos largou um
quarto com uma cama brilhante uma
família abriga várias páginas e um
carneiro agora eu tenho uma pessoa carro
um carro atacou triplo uma pessoa vai
dar a volta e estamos devem estar a
contar uma história que o supostamente
aconteceu antes e não sei se a minha mãe
e minha avó mas possivelmente eu sou
aquela pessoa ver né eu sou criança é
minha mãe queimava e agora voltamos a
família outra vez
agora minha mãe tem um demônio trás de
um demônio do mundo com 1 com mais um
ônibus na volta e já não há mais páginas
embora agora esperam o flash lite agora
sim já tem 11 já consegue ver o que eu
vou fazer né
agora isto funciona a sério a suposta
bruxa e microondas tamandaré
caso alguma coisa estranha ver uma casa
de banho não consegui nada
todo mundo está morto mas encheram
zombies e não um filho não posso deixar
meu filho morreu ao salvar meu filho vai
tomar algumas voltas de bicicleta ou não
eu não sei o que aconteceu a tua mãe do
meu filho iria falar porque todo o
estado para caraças folha alguém que
escadas e morreu
será que minha mãe que ela determinar o
país não é assim tão assustador porque
não está muito ruins isto é a minha mãe
morreu ao bater na avó e não se batem em
vôo choque ok agora nós vamos rever o
enforcamento filha o que aconteceu
porque os móveis têm que ser tão
complicados o blog isto está aqui mais
um boneco aqui qualquer coisa eo cofre
não é uma chave
com esta porta exatamente a uma lá em
cima também está fechada na outra chave
que esta deve ser só porto acima eu acho
que é a única porta estava fechada agora
vou conseguir alguma luz do demônio que
aquilo ou outra página e entramos dentro
de uma caixa
será que aqui onde tenho que manter os
bonecos eu não sei se fazer alguma coisa
mas fomos lá para baixo através de luta
com desenhos para lá e possibilita a
água a água a água não acredito que um
filho dentro do laboratório filho não é
casa de banho em casa tudo bem também
não está acontecendo nada
o filho filho levanta te e eu sei que já
está morto mas mantém a mesma filho eu
preciso da minha vida é ou não não é o
nosso filho para apanhar agora né
a família é família está toda no quarto
meu deus está muito alto alô
não sei se estou incomodar ou não mas eu
gostaria de cinta que vivo pode ser
daqui vamos embora lamentável falta em
cima o pessoal vamos ficar por aqui com
este vídeo espero que vocês tenham
gostado este fui o jogo misto mais em
toda a minha vida a sério está brutal o
jogo não trouxe nada de especial em
texturas e etc mas jesus está muito bom
e eu já posso ver os jogos do torneio
para caraças dois só sabem tudo que
mostrei que favorito espero que vocês
tenham gostado fiquem bem e até a
próxima e agora vou trocar que está tudo
sujo
o